volver a respirar con tranquilidad en el
transporte público desde el lunes en
francia no será obligatorio llevar la
mascarilla en el metro en trenes ni en
aviones
mucha gente ya ni siquiera la usaba
había tantas que no se respetaban las
reglas así que es mejor que la eliminen
por completo así será más fácil el hueco
y una vez no fue tan malo si no esté
obligado a usar máscara no lo haré pero
esta opinión no parece ser ampliamente
compartida ya que muchos usuarios del
transporte público dicen que seguirán
usando la máscara tengo el estado de
salud delicado y no me interesa pasar mi
tiempo en el hospital así que creo que
lo seguiré usando porque me he
acostumbrado a usarlo en los últimos dos
años mantendré la buena costumbre
esta es la razón por la que pronto se
volverán a ver los rostros en el metro
una caída significativa en los nuevos
contagios diarios en comparación con el
pico de casi medio millón de casos en
enero es muy importante que los que
estén enfermos que tengan síntomas o los
que estén en contacto sigan usando la
mascarilla pueden contagiar durante
varios días a personas con salud frágil
que no están tan bien protegidas
la agencia europea de seguridad aérea
también ha eliminado la mascarilla
obligatoria en los aeropuertos y en
todos los vuelos y aquí es donde se
complica alemania dijo que la medida
seguirá siendo obligatoria en todos los
vuelos que despeguen y aterricen en el
país